5:06 bible these are the numbers of a
treasure trove six 506 506 to a mother
with no child took a soul greetings a
peace to everybody all over the world
tuning into the DS show this week's show
is surrounded by mystery full of
controversy and the former US Attorney
General Ramsey Clark has said about it
that he hasn't seen witnessed such bear
injustice in his entire career along
with former US presidential candidate
and two-time Senator Michael Garvin
who's also advocating on behalf of this
woman along with the hundreds of
thousands of peaceful protestors we're
not terrorists but have mothers and
daughters of their own who just want
justice they want to know the truth
because they cried their hearts cry out
of sympathy and sorrow imagine if
something like this happened to their
own family members so we're gonna let
you decide is this woman one of the
world's greatest terrorists that was
taken off the street or was she a victim
or was she innocently accused and
arrested kidnapped tortured raped and as
the Attorney General stated a victim of
the greatest injustice that he has ever
seen and then falsely imprisoned to
spend the rest of her life in jail
I don't know but we want to know the
truth and then let you decide and then
you decide and my next guest who's been
on this case he's dedicated his life to
this case he's a peace and human rights
advocate activists will let me right
back with him to get the full picture of
this story when we come back don't go
anyway this
[Music]
this is the peace be with you
Salam alaykoum how are you fine I'm
Delilah we don't have much time these
programs of short I introduced a program
it's a very sad situation has happened
and I want to kind of bring this to
light so people out there you know
good-hearted people such as the attorney
a former attorney general former US
presidential candidate and many others
Christians actually you actually
nominated is true for the dr. Martin
Luther King award by a Christian
organization is that right yes the the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King's
juniors organization that he founded the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
awarded me with their their special
award years ago Minh the immediate
aftermath of one of the big cases in the
Washington DC area involving a young man
by the name of Terrence Johnson and
Prince George's County police this
police issue with that for the
african-american community has been
going on for years and years and years
so like this was in the mid 90s I think
in yeah in the aftermath of that
successful campaign we received that
award
so you're out there advocating human
rights forever for everybody that's
right
the Prophet peace be upon him said when
you see an evil action change it with
your hand if you cannot do so with your
tongue and your harlot the tongue if you
cannot do so detested within your heart
and that is the weakest degree of faith
and that wasn't conditional on if it's a
Muslim anyone if you see an evil action
so we've been at this for quite some
time and yes we have been involved in
cases involving involving non-muslims as
well as Muslims so this is this is the
last final messenger who made a
statement from Mohammed peace be upon
him Jesus was honest was on the same
mission who we love and revere as one of
the mightiest messengers of God Jesus
peace be upon him Moses Abraham they
were all about calling people to peace
and human rights also right that's right
so tell us now I mentioned the former US
Attorney General also the president
former presidential candidate two-time
senator and so many other people are
advocating on behalf of this woman how
did they get involved how did you get
involved how do I and to get here today
with us yeah the former Congresswoman is
Cynthia McKinney also went to Pakistan
like dr. Aafia Siddiqui
well her case I became involved in ah
Thea's case about a year after she was
brought back to the United States
she was brought back in 2008 half dead
after being shot and by a American
soldier who panicked shot her and and
this came after five years of secret
imprisonment and torture so she was in
bad shape
barely alive about a year later I
delivered a sermon a khutba at a large
Center in Maryland and it just so
happens someone was in the audience that
the new audio Thea's case I was in the
congregation I should say the new
obvious case and walked up to me
afterward and asked me if I knew la
fiesta deke he was and when I responded
that I had heard her name but really
didn't know much about the case
she then asked would you like to know
more and I said yes I ended a meeting
with her and her parents and one thing
led to another once I became apprised of
what some of the facts were and then
began to do my own research on the case
the more
I realized this was one of the worst
cases I had ever seen and that was again
about a year after she was brought back
to the US so now it's been just over
five years that I've been involved in
her case and over this five year period
we've been successful by the grace and
mercy of Allah in bringing more people
on board including some prominent folk
now that's the same thing that the
former attorney US General who this
status is at is a person who is like the
chief lawyer the chief advocate of
justice in the United States and his
time right and he was one of the best
during his time he said the same thing
this is the form of worse injustice that
he's ever seen the US career the US
Attorney General is the highest law
enforcement officer in the land in my
humble opinion Ramsey Clark who at 85
years old is still active I mean last
year we we made two requests two very
important requests of Ramsey Clark we
asked him if he would be willing to go
overseas and meet the family of apphia
and also you know just talk to public
officials and encouraged them and
Pakistan to do more to get their citizen
back he did that he went travel to
Pakistan and then when he came back
after a trip to Venezuela he joined us
in Fort Worth Texas where Alfie is being
held and after he delivered his speech
one of the things that he said was that
this case involving dr. Aafia Siddiqui
is the worst case of individual and
justice he's ever seen so for someone of
his stature 85 years old still active
former US Attorney General traveling all
over the world he's seen much as says a
lot before we go to break now there's a
lot of there are a lot of misconceptions
and myths according to this it's a it's
a mystery a lot of controversy and most
people the detials dedicated to clearing
too many misconceptions about Islam
because many people they don't know
Islam they think Islam is associated
with terrorism and all these things that
Islam is free of killing of innocent men
women and children
you know Islam is free of this Muslims
are peaceful people who who live
according to you know the way that Jesus
lived Moses and all the other messengers
trying to have peace with their creator
peace with themselves they're not we're
not trying to blow nobody up right so
now you hear al Qaeda and you hear all
of this other things associated with her
I'm sure a US Attorney General would get
involved to smear his name after his
great reputation if this was true what
do you have to say about all these
things of her being like the chief al
Qaeda it's all it's all nonsense if and
I've been at this for a long time I've
been in courthouses all over the land I
know the law I know how the law is used
and at times misuse if the government
had had a shred of evidence or anything
that they could hang any accusation on
Afiya would have been charged with the
terrorism offense she was not charged
with one terrorism offense not not even
one not even conspiracy to commit act an
act of terrorism and that said to me
clearly that the government came to a
realization that they had made a mistake
we're gonna take a break and on this
break one of the top journalists was
also dedicated to this case we're gonna
let people listen to this and then we're
gonna come back and you're gonna tell us
through a unique way her story through
an actual comic book it how does that
sound
it sounds good we'll be right back here
on the Deen show what more in the course
of the trial the only evidence against
her there was no forensic so the only
evidence against her came from the
soldiers who were present and according
to not one but several lawyers I've
spoken to those soldiers in the
courtroom contradicted each other but
also contradicted the initial statements
that they made about who stood where and
who was there and when she did this and
where she was exactly so I think it's
it's a tragic a tragic thing for
American justice that the jury found her
guilty but in the climate of New York
post 9/11 somebody whose reputation had
been completely trashed to deliberately
by the people who leaked stories that
she was a guy
Ronna or a money launderer for al-qaeda
that she was married into a big al-qaeda
family all these things were lies but
they were put out into the media and so
not surprisingly in America people who
didn't know any of the details had an
image of her and it was that false image
which allowed her to be convicted as for
getting 86 years outrageous is the only
possible word for this sentence she had
often mistranslated as holy war the word
jihad means to struggle Islam does not
preach violence it does not preach
vicious holy war it certainly does not
condone terror and suicide bombing Islam
preaches compassion tolerance and
justice find the truth about Islam call
toll-free 877 why Islam back here on the
D show now you just got to hear what the
one of the top journalists who was
reporting on this case she just said and
I had kind of went in line with the
question you know you know a lot of
these things that were associated with
her being with al-qaeda and being this
and being that and she just comment on
that what are you what are your comments
on what she said well that is one of my
favorite clips and I'm so glad that you
you've included that in this show
she was point on this is a respected
journalist from from the UK and she
attended the trial she she was point on
with her observations that this case
involving a surrounding dr. Aafia
Siddiqui has been surrounded by a
bodyguard of lies and the last point
that she made reminded me of something
that cindy sheehan very respected
anti-war activists here in the united
states an observation as she made a
concerning apphia and the sentence that
she received for what she was accused of
doing she said quote even if dr.
Siddiqui did shoot at the americans
reflect on this saying this case was
being tried in pakistan under similar
circumstances
foreign
American woman named dr. Betty Brown who
was captured and repeatedly tortured and
raped by the ISI here in the States
that woman would be a hero if she shot
at her captors not demonized and taken
away from her life and her children and
so again what Victoria said was spot-on
and it's something that should cause
every fair-minded American or anyone
else who sees this program who was
fair-minded
a great amount of pause and reflection
before we get into this uniques way of
presenting this story and I want to ask
you so we had we talked about Ramsey
Clark we'll get more into that later US
Attorney General who's on the case who's
advocating for her meaning that he's out
there you know brothers to the public
eye real quick I want you to see we also
the former presidential candidate
two-time senator what he had to say
about this and again I'm here in
Pakistan to plead the cause for dr.
Aafia Siddiqui who's in jail in the
United States unjustly and that we need
to pressure the Pakistani government to
ask for her repatriation to Pakistan
it's a great injustice
you know there's injustice all over the
world but when we become acquainted with
one single person who has suffered
tremendous injustice it morality begs us
to stand up and use our voice to ask for
justice with respect to doctors Aafia
Siddiqui I am NOT a terrorist
sympathizer al-qaeda sympathizer you're
not nodding
Ramzi Attorney General is not now this
former presidential candidate a patriot
of America we just had we got to hear
what he had to say I'm and 100 percent
he's knocked or the other congresswoman
who was the other woman that you face in
McKinney Cynthia McKinney she's a common
torture
George Walmart former Congresswoman from
Georgia okay so these people just want
justice mm-hmm
they're advocating because this could be
your mother your daughter tomorrow what
do you have to say about what he said
you know as dr. Martin Luther King said
and this is a quotation that is often
visited by by people across the world
injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere obvious case is a
precedent-setting case one of the things
that Greville just said was that there
are a lot of cases there a lot of
there's a lot of injustice out there and
there is but there are certain cases
that the the the stuff that surrounds
them is is so weighty that they are
correctly viewed as a precedent-setting
you know and the precedent at the end of
the day can be positive or it can be
negative depending upon the outcome of
the case what I've been saying in
different parts of the country when I
talk about Alfia Siddiqui and one of the
reasons why you know while we still deal
with other cases involving other
political prisoners and people
wrongfully injured issues of a human
rights nature this case gets the lion's
share of our time energy and attention
because of the weight of it the
precedent-setting nature of it if this
can happen to her and if our government
can get away with doing this to her
no one is safe that's the bottom line if
this can happen to a woman like this who
who came from Pakistan when she was 18
graduated with honors from two of the
finest Ivy League universities in the
world MIT and Brandeis I mean we have
this distinguished career and this this
extracurricular activity as a human
rights oriented person concerned about
Dawa and humanitarian relief for those
who need it most
if this can happen to her it can happen
to anyone
we're gonna tell her story now in a
unique way who was dr. Aafia Siddiqui
dr. Aafia Siddiqui is a neuroscientist
who study the MIT and brand
specifically she studied how to improve
the education system for disabled
children while attending school Afiya
volunteered in a class to help real
children benefit from the improvements
she made she also found time to become a
leader in the Muslim Student Association
friends still remember her tearful pleas
for Refugees how can you have more than
one pair of shoes when our brothers in
Bosnia are freezing
despite the busy schedule of a student
Afiya gave presentations constantly
about the humanitarian crisis in Bosnia
she also collected currents for
prisoners carrying the heavy boxes
herself even when she was pregnant on
top of all of her academic achievements
dr. Siddiqui is also a hafiz' of Quran
one who has memorized the Quran in March
of 2003 dr. Siddiqui left her mother's
house in Pakistan for the Karachi
Airport and disappeared along with her
children
dr. Siddiqui mysteriously reappeared in
2008 in Afghanistan shortly before an
incident that nearly killed her
where was she for five years a secretly
recorded tape was handed to sadiki's
lawyers where a Pakistani Superintendent
of Police admits to being personally
involved in sadiki's abduction her
oldest son Ahmed remembers being stopped
enroute to the airport he recounts that
they were destined excuse me they were
detained by 15 to 20 people including a
white lady another witness present saw
Siddiqui slapped across her face Ahmed
saw his six-month-old brother Suleiman
fall to the ground Suleiman has ever
been seen again this is the last of what
Achmed remembers before he was separated
from his family and made to inhale
something that knocked him out on the
same day that Siddiqui and her children
disappeared her mother was threatened by
a man in a motorcycle helmet he warned
her to not report her daughter as
missing the Pakistani newspaper dawn
reported soon after that Siddiqui was in
Pakistani custody
as did NBC Nightly News both would later
retract the story the FBI also met with
her family they said Siddiqui was alive
but would answer no questions about her
whereabouts all of a sudden the media
reported different kinds of stories
doctor Siddiqui was accused of being a
courier for blood diamonds from Liberia
she had been in Boston at the time the
story was faint but damage had already
been done in 2004 John Ashcroft declared
to the nation that afiyah was quote the
most dangerous woman in the world end
quote doctor sadiq he was quickly being
turned into a boogeyman to justify the
war on terrorists why was she captured
in the four years between 2001 and 2005
it is estimated that the government of
pervez musharraf handed over 400 to 800
prisoners to the United States many were
innocent but their capture made the war
on terror seem justified a few weeks
before Siddiqui disappeared Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed was captured he was
waterboarded a hundred and eighty three
times in his first month of imprisonment
court I gave a lot of false information
to satisfy what I believed the
interrogators wish to hear end quote
supposedly Mohammed named names leading
to the capture of both Majid Khan and
Siddiqui Khan was taken to Guantanamo
Khan was tortured so much that he
attempted suicide by biting through an
artery so based on the words of men
trying to escape torture Siddiqui was
caught and tormented herself
where was Siddiqui between her abduction
in 2003 and reappearance in 2008 Binion
Mohammed another innocent victim of the
war on terror who endured seven years of
detention and torture at the hands of
the US government claims that he saw
Siddiqui at the notorious us-run prison
in Bagram Afghanistan she was the only
female prisoner
and the men refer to her as the grey
lady of bug row
night by night or night after night they
would hear her cries dr. Siddiqui who
was told by the judge that her years of
secret attention were irrelevant to her
trial confirms that she was indeed L did
bug room she was subjected to all kinds
of torture physical psychological and
sexual in one horrific instance guards
desecrated a Koran and forced her to
walk barefoot on the torn pages the male
prisoners sickened by the screams of a
woman who was clearly being tortured
staged a hunger strike in her defense
one day without explanation Siddiqui was
dropped off in a confused state she was
released on a street in Afghanistan this
is your son he has got that big it has
been that long she was handed a bag by
the people who released her some have
suspected that Siddiqui was being sent
off defenseless to her death but
something unexpected happened she walked
in a different direction when she heard
the call to prayer see they are calling
come to Salah come to success she was
stopped and detained the bag she was
handed supposedly contained instructions
for explosives but doctor sadiq he was
never charged with terrorism there are
two versions of the events had followed
while Siddiqui was detained at an Afghan
police station the u.s. claims she was
behind a curtain that she spotted a
weapon and picked it up emerging from
behind the curtain she fired the at
Afghan police and American soldiers
hitting nothing she wrestled men to the
ground and was shot because they
defended themselves the supposed
witnesses had conflicting testimonies
disagreeing on details like whether she
was standing or sitting and only the
American witnesses
back this version of events dr. sadiki's
version of the story puts her behind a
curtain too but little else is similar
hearing American voices she feared being
returned to Bagram she peered out
looking for a possible escape route one
of the armed men saw her and yelled
she's free before shooting her multiple
times in the abdomen she was nearly
killed the prosecution claimed bullet
holes at the station were made by
Siddiqui firing a weapon but a video in
the US government's possession for
months shows the same bullet holes three
there the day before Siddiqui arrived
while recovering dr. Siddiqui was
restrained to the bed and denied guests
save for FBI agents they claimed that
she made confessions which would be
convenient since no forensic evidence
exists to support the story where
Siddiqui went on a shooting rampage a
mere seven days after being shot and
nearly killed dr. Siddiqui was brought
to New York with no extradition to face
charges of attempted murder
lady al-qaeda as they called her the
most dangerous woman in the world was
never charged with terrorism
IMed who disappeared with his mother in
2003 was released to his family in 2008
he was interrogated upon his return to
Pakistan it is still unknown where he
was detained for all those years the
middle child Miriam was dropped off
mysteriously a note was tied to her with
her mother's excuse me with her
grandmother's address written on it she
was only able to speak English and with
an American accent hello it took a DNA
test to confirm that she was sadiki's
daughter the third and youngest child
sulieman' remains missing since the 2003
abduction and is feared dead dr.
sadiki's trial in New York was a sham
she was not allowed to pick her defense
team the jury was not set sequestered
free to read and be influenced by
propaganda against Siddiqui and though
she was never charged with terrorism
the prosecution raised the specter of
terrorism constantly the prosecution
asks her about chemists chemistry
training she had in school realizing
that they brought up this irrelevant
detail to paint her as a bomb maker or
worse she exclaimed you can't build a
case on hate you should build it on
facts Siddiqui was sentenced to 86 years
in prison realizing her trial to be a
sham her parting words to the judge were
nonetheless compassionate judge I
forgive you
I beg thank you his response thank you I
wish other people were like you you will
now be spending the rest of your life in
federal penitentiary
Afiya I beg to differ from you
my fate lies with Allah and my destiny
is with my lord the decision of my fate
is my God's not yours and mr. judge I
thank you for letting me graduate from
another MIT the Manhattan Institute of
theatrical arts Siddiqui was sent to the
notorious Carswell prison where abuse of
the female prisoners has been rampant
and though she was never charged with
terrorism
dr. sadiki's imprisonment includes harsh
terror enhancements her family was
repeatedly denied of his visitation when
asked about this a guard answered with
surprising honesty the normal rules
don't apply to your sister meanwhile
sadiki's family has been faced with
constant harassment would-be kidnappers
attempted to abduct her children again
and sadiki's mother has received death
threats
I believe dr. Siddiqui is a political
prisoner and now the political boogey
woman for two u.s. regimes it's a quote
from Cindy Sheehan and Aktau anti-war
activists Afiya was a victim of
rendition of torture of a sham trial she
is a victim like so many of the
so-called war on terror she is not
forgotten it was a great presentation in
a unique way through a comic book and
the person we're almost out of time who
did this is actually wasn't a Muslim was
a non-muslim that's right is a young
college student by the name of
Christopher town Chris did an excellent
job telling Navia story in that format
and it's a again another example of just
how far this concern for this Muslim
woman has spread just a couple more
points really short we're out of time
we've gone past our time tell us you
were there during the trial I was there
for the entire trial did you hear her
say this to the judge
yes she's and in fact I said I went at
one point
Afiya and this really emphasizes the
character of Athiya after five years of
secret imprisonment and torture another
roughly 18 months before of of
imprisonment pretrial confinement in a
maximum-security detention center in New
York that violated the Constitution's
guarantee against cruel and unusual
punishment and on the day when she is
given a sentence of 86 years not only
does she express forgiveness for the
Judge Richard Berman who who presided
over this farce but she even turned to
the audience in the courtroom and those
who are in the overflow in another room
where a monitor was set up and she said
to them to everyone that was in that
space and those beyond the space that
would hear her message later on
she did not want any violence done in
her name no violence
as a result of what has happened to her
you know she said that you know I'm just
one person terrible things have happened
to people far more important than I you
know no violence in my name she said no
but last point that goes back to what
was in the story she wasn't charged with
terrorism that's right
and she had a new this is a fact she had
nothing no links didn't work for
al-qaeda she wasn't out of al-qaeda none
this is zero no this is false
that's right okay that's it closing
comments you got 10 15 seconds we're out
I know what you have to say I guess or
we leave I want I want to say I want to
quote two prominent figures one from the
Islamic tradition and one from the
Western tradition Shay Given Tamia Rahim
o Allah he said civilization is based on
justice and the consequences of
oppression are devastating therefore it
is said Allah aids the just state even
if it is non-muslim yet withholds his
health from the oppressive State even if
it is Muslim former president and
founding father Thomas Jefferson said I
tremble for my country when I reflect
that God is just his justice cannot
sleep forever this is a challenge to us
all Muslim and non-muslim that the
health and welfare of our communities of
our nation depends upon our willingness
to stand for truth and stand for justice
thank you so much for being with us
thank you we started with peace we end
with peace peace people view a salami
what he comes sylvalum brother thank you
now before we conclude just a couple
points I want you to think about and
something that you can do on your end
one is think about and ponder if
individuals people of consciousness
people who are alive and awake and are
thinking clearly you know we get fed a
lot of things from the media but if you
look at this Washington Post score cards
that were published to have a look here
from Fox News and you can see the amount
of true
half-truths and falsehood that we're
being told on a daily basis so I told
you in the beginning that this case is
surrounded by mystery and a lot of
controversy but if people such as great
people such as former US Attorney
General Ramsey Clark and Senator two
times senator and former presidential
candidate Mike Garvin if people like
this and others hundreds of thousands of
peaceful protesters out there you know
along with the attorney general of
people like this can get involved and
they they're out there creating
awareness why can't you why can't you
create awareness of this I know myself
that the more I study Islam the more I
look at the evidences it proves it makes
me a better human being
helps me to be more merciful and loving
because this is what islam teaches to be
loving and kind with all of mankind so
now when you get to know islam you truly
get to know it yes there are atrocities
that are committed and we condemn these
things on both sides but we as muslims
need to be at a higher level at a higher
standard as the Creator tells us in the
verbatim word of god the koran to repel
evil with what is better not worse and
God Almighty has sent the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him as the last
and final messenger who was a brother to
Jesus and Moses they all brought the
same message worship the Creator not the
Christ should do good deeds and we fear
doing any injustice to a human being to
even an animal
so now innocent people that go over to
Syria they go over to help
journalists aid workers a Muslim no
Muslim in his right mind who knows Islam
can even think about beheading or
killing an innocent person because this
is clear if the Prophet Muhammad Allah
calls of God calls him as a mercy to the
world he was sent as a mercy to the
world and God Almighty tells us that he
will not have mercy on those who do not
have mercy to the
as creatures on earth so just as Islam
helps me to be more loving and kind and
merciful and I feared doing any harm to
any human being unjustly so do over 1.7
billion Muslims all over the world who
live a religion of peace and mercy and
justice so Islam is free of this free of
terrorism and all these other crazy
barbaric things that our people are
trying to associate with it and we wish
that the media would give the microphone
to people who have condemned these
things give the spotlight to the good
that Muslims are doing but it's
shamefully they want to focus on the
0.111 small fringe elements that have
nothing to do with Islam but now you on
the other note if you've watched this we
really want to create awareness about
this so you have a moral obligation
share this on your Facebook on your
Twitter's if you've been a guest on the
show you've a scholar student not
acknowledge it I do add and now you've
watched this share this the least you
can do to create awareness of this and
make dua for this sister and tune in
every week to the Deen show we hope that
this has gotten a chance to
enlightenment people this is not a
Muslim thing this is a human thing for
all of those who are tuning in
non-muslim not yet Muslim Muslim
brothers in humanity we need to wake
work together to make this world a
better place a place where there is true
justice and peace for all and we'll see
you next time here in the D show until
then peace be with you
Salaam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind we'll see you next
time
God willing on today's show continue to
tune in peace be unto you please
subscribe to the D show follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]